♪♪
-New year, fresh start.
Couple of resolutions.
No more callbacks...
in "Corrections."
I want each one
to be self-contained
so people can jump in.
They're incentivized
to start watching now.
Another one of my resolutions --
get back to the gym.
Took a couple of weeks off.
Made a difference.
Here is a picture
from earlier today.
[ Laughter ]
So no more callbacks.
Hey, I was told
my Jennifer Coolidge impression
sounds like my
Owen Wilson impression,
which is deeply wrong
because Jennifer Coolidge
is like, "Wow!"
But Owen Wilson is "Wow!"
It's about the eyes
are either open or like,
"Wow."
"Wow!"
My impression of the two of them
realizing they're wearing the
same sweater at a holiday party.
"Wow!"
Sounds the same?
Uh, ooh.
Here. Can we come over there
for a second?
We did a --
I leaned my head back
in "A Closer Look" on Monday,
and a bunch of people noticed
I had a scar on my chin
and asked why I have a scar on
my chin.
Have any of you seen
the movie "Road House"?
[ Laughter ]
In the film "Road House,"
Patrick Swayze
plays a bouncer,
the head bouncer,
the kind of guy
who's going to do
whatever it takes
to win a fight.
He's going to break the rules.
He's going to put himself
at risk when things get gnarly.
Anyway, when I was 16, I was on
the couch watching that movie
and I leaned over
to get popcorn.
I rolled over, and I banged this
on the coffee table.
[ Laughter ]
That's actually not
how I hurt it.
The only thing
I'm going to say --
the only true thing
I'm gonna say about it is
Shoemaker didn't do it.
[ Laughter ]
It's not "pri-mer,"
it's "prim-er."
You're nodding, you know,
because it's British.
And Amazon "Prim" is when
they bring your package
[British accent] in a lorry.
[ Light laughter ]
You don't mix cocaine
with baking powder.
You mix it with baking soda.
An error I made so many times
they kicked me off the corner.
[ Laughter ]
I had a very small part...
got cut...
from season one of "The Wire."
Where I played a dealer
who got it wrong.
I was like,
"I'm so sorry, Avon."
Graphics.
One person we talked about --
we made a very hard graphic
in an effort to show
that they had not...
lost their touch
over a long hiatus.
And it was an alligator
drinking from a beer helmet
in a golf cart
with a bumper sticker that said,
"My other ride is your mom."
We were very impressed,
but when he pointed out
that is not on the bumper,
therefore that is not
a bumper sticker.
That seems to me a little...
a little severe.
With that said, we also
before the break had
Rudy Giuliani
wearing his shirts as pants
and his pants as a shirt,
and people said,
"That's not good."
And, yeah, I get it.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know what we thought
it would look like,
but I don't -- I don't know
if that was it.
You guys,
my goal with "Corrections"
is to make you feel
part of this "Late Night" family
because this is a great place
to work with great people.
And so you guys
being a part of this,
obviously there's a good amount
of inside jokes,
but I want you to feel like
you're a part of this family.
And one of the best parts
of this family
is when we sort of gently
tease each other
and I feel nothing
warms my heart more
than when I feel
like you guys get that
because one of you --
we mentioned this.
We showed this picture
of an old Santa Claus
in last "Corrections"
and someone said,
"Hey, I know
what that looks like.
That looks like Wally in respect
in the workplace."
[ Laughter ]
You guys get it.
So burning Wally is great.
Burning me, on the other hand,
is not cool.
And I was on --
I use this as a safe place
to share with you
how unsettled I am by the 1980s
McDonald's spokesperson
Mac Tonight.
And instead of empathizing
with me
and hearing that, many of you
have taken advantage of the P.O.
Box address we have given you
to send me just awful --
awful, haunting...
This showed up in the mail.
That dude.
A mug.
And then this note,
which just, again, says,
"Forever yours, love
always and forever, Mac."
Just again, a serial killer's
note card.
Guys, stop sending me
Mac Tonight stuff.
We're going to flash
the P.O. Box one more time.
[ Laughter ]
Just so you remember,
if you have it,
this is the last place
we want it.
[ Laughter ]
Last "Corrections," it turned
out some of the stuff
at the desk was made of candy.
It was edible.
That was our big reveal.
[ Laughter ]
I should note they were courtesy
of our sound mixers.
His name is Mike Witzer.
His mother, Andrea,
does this for a living.
This is a true thing.
She has -- You can go to
www.stylewith.me
to see the incredible
work she does.
And I'm going to use her.
I think I'm going to make
edible versions
of my kids' favorite toys.
And then when they misbehave...
[ Laughter ]
She can do anything.
I was told she can.
I mean, she can't do like paper,
but she can do like, you know,
anything with, like a shape.
I took a bite of of this.
And based on the reaction,
people thought,
"Oh, my God,
he thought that was candy."
But it turned out
it was plaster.
It was something worse
than plaster.
It was white chocolate.
[ Laughter ]
Which used to be my nickname.
That was actually my
character's name on "The Wire."
[ Laughter ]
You guys,
I am a Pittsburgh Steelers fan.
I live and die
with the Pittsburgh Steelers.
Not something I'm proud of
or I think makes me cool.
If anything, I would consider it
a sort of design flaw.
Doesn't make me more interesting
to be around.
If I was ever on a dating show,
it wouldn't be my introduction.
"Hey, I'm Seth.
I cry when the Steelers lose
and also when they win."
I know.
[ Laughter ]
It sucks. Well, they weren't
having much of a season.
And then they kind of
turned it around.
And not only have things
been going well for them,
but all the teams that need to
lose need to lose,
and so now a thing that I did
not think was possible --
it's possible they might
actually make the playoffs.
Three things need to happen
on Sunday.
They have to win,
the Bills have to beat
the Patriots,
and the Jets have to
beat the Dolphins.
Now, if you watch this show,
you know
I'm pretty hard on the Jets.
[ Laughter ]
And if you're a Buddhist,
you might have heard
about something called karma.
I'm well aware of how this is
likely going to end.
You know what I mean?
Like, I need the Jets to win.
And the thing that really
burns me is
either John or Jim --
I can't remember who --
I mean, they both,
like, tower above me.
[ Laughter ]
So whenever they talk, I look.
They're always backlit.
[ Laughter ]
But I remember one of them
once was like, "You know,
you better be careful."
Oh, so it was Jim.
[ Laughter ]
He said,
"You better be careful.
You know, one of these days
you might need
the Jets to win."
And I was like,
"If I ever need to root
for the New York Jets,
I'll eat my script, Jim."
[ Laughter ]
Point being...
I really want the Jets to win.
And Mike's mom
"can" make candy paper.
[ Laughter ]
She told me it was edible.
But now...
I think if I swallow it,
I'll die.
Real pencil? Is it pencil?
Shoemaker, is it pencil?
Shoemaker!
Is it pencil?
Shoemaker, is it pencil?
Shoemaker!
[ Laughter ]
Shoemaker, is it pencil?
-Yes.
-Don't [bleep] talk...
[ Laughter ]
...in "Corrections."
Not pencil, you dummy.